Venezuela está de vuelta gobierno y
oposición firmaron un nuevo acuerdo con
el que buscan recuperar recursos del
Estado bloqueados en el sistema
financiero internacional en el acuerdo
figura cooperación en gastos
humanitarios como el pago de proyectos
de atención médica valorados en más de
2.700 millones de dólares y la
reparación de redes eléctricas el
presidente Nicolás Maduro lo celebró en
Twitter la firma del segundo acuerdo
parcial entre el gobierno bolivariano
que preside y la plataforma unitaria de
una de las oposiciones abre paso a un
nuevo capítulo para Venezuela en función
de seguir avanzando hacia la paz y el
bienestar que todas y todos los
venezolanos anhelamos Este es el segundo
acuerdo que llega después de que la mesa
de negociación política fuese suspendida
formalmente en octubre de 2021 sin
embargo Venezuela trata de recuperar
activos perdidos e internacionalmente y
aprovechar su posición en un mercado
energético en crisis esto se demuestra
cuando instantes después del anuncio de
la firma entre gobierno y oposición el
departa del tesoro de Estados Unidos
informó que autoriza a la petrolera
Chevron a retomar operaciones limitadas
de extracción de recursos naturales esta
acción refleja la política de larga Data
de Estados Unidos de proporcionar un
alivio de sanciones específico basado en
pasos concretos que alivian el
sufrimiento del pueblo venezolano y
apoyan la restauración de la Democracia
movimientos que confirman que Venezuela
está de vuelta en el tablero político
internacional